comme free vous avez été ministre des
affaires étrangères rêver vous avez été
la femme forte du gouvernement à
l'étranger auprès de monsieur trompe
aujourd'hui vous êtes vous avez un
mandat canadien auprès des provinces
vous êtes l'émissaire de tahoua dans le
fond avec les gouvernements provinciaux
kehl comment vous voyez ce défi je pense
que c'est peut-être que le plus grand
défi que le gouvernement a aujourd'hui
et pour cette raison le premier ministre
m'a demandé de faire ça pour lui et avec
lui pour nous pour le premier ministre
les élections a été très importante le
résultat des élections et c'était pour
lui important de faire des réflexions et
que les canadiens de la division la de
la grogne résultats dans l'ouest le
résultat au québec c'est ça vous y jouez
est exactement et c'était une message
pour nous pour les libérales pour notre
gouvernement
et j'apprécie beaucoup le fait que le
premier ministre a répondu à cette
message il a réagi pourquoi pourquoi
vous pourquoi vous particulièrement
pourquoi vous avez l'impression que vous
êtes la personne pour faire ce travail
je vais citer le premier ministre parce
que il a dit une chose mercredi à
laquelle je suis vraiment d'accord et
c'était que en travaillant ensemble sur
alana - et le premier ministre nous
avons découvrit que on travaille très
bien ensemble et que nous sommes une
bonne équipe et nous allons essayer de
prendre la proche que en a pris avec les
négociations de allen n'est maintenant
du utilise d'utiliser cette approche
dans nos conversations avec les
canadiens et canadiennes votre votre
plus gros défi quality vous avez un
résultat particulier au québec avec la
présence du black vous avez clairement
une division en alberta et en
saskatchewan vous avez élu
aucun candidat quel est votre défi le
plus important d'après vous maintenant
le défi le plus important est dû
préserver l'unité nationale du canada et
je dois dire que en tant que ministre
des affaires étrangères j'ai appris deux
choses importantes à premièrement en
voyageant beaucoup à l'étrangère g vous
notre pays
-dans une manière un peu différente et
j'ai compris à que notre pays vraiment
et ip merveille et que notre pays
aujourd'hui est la démocratie libérale
que le plus forte dans le monde et c'est
le devoir du fédéral de trouver une
manière du travail ensemble d'être
équipe canada c'est ce qu'on a fait
pendant les négociations de l anah et on
est content mais faire ça et je vais je
voudrais dire une chose de québec
si je peux aller 0 1 j'ai apprécié
beaucoup pendant les négociations avec
l'union européenne les négociations du
site à et aussi pendant les négociations
de l'alena notre étroite collaboration
avec le québec le québec comprend très
très bien comment faire les négociations
internationales et on a vraiment une
bonne collaboration et j'espère que ce
soit possible de continuer sa deux
éléments que je veux révéla d'abord vous
avez parlé d'unité nationale au début
est-ce que l'unité nationale est en
péril à l'heure actuelle je pense que je
crois que a
les canadiens et les canadiennes
comprend l'importance d'unité nationale
mais on doit travailler sur ça peut être
je peux utiliser
une exemple personnel je suis marié
maintenant 21 ans et j'adore mon mari
mais je sais que de temps en temps on
doit travailler sur le mariage pour
avoir un bon mariage il y a des moments
qu on doit faire plus attention aux
partenariats et peut-être c'est ce qu'on
doit faire pour notre famille notre
grand mariage nationale maintenant
enfin le salon du mariage dans l'ouest
alors à l'alberta la saskatchewan qui
sera vraisemblablement l'une de vos
premières destinations je sais que c'est
pas décidé encore je vous ai entendu
dire souvent cette semaine nous allons
écouter
nous allons écouter et c'est louable
mais vous avez 24 mois à peu près en
moyenne un gouvernement minoritaire sa
durée et en alberta
on veut des résultats et des gestes
concrets qu'est ce que vous allez faire
pour moi la chose importante du débit et
c'est seulement 3 4 jours je fais ce
travail c'est vraiment important de
commencer en écoutant et d'avoir une
vraie conversation
si tu commences à une conversation en
disant oui je veux tu écoutais mais je
veux te dire avant du écoutez je vais
faire ça et ça et je ne peux pas faire
ça et ça ce n'est pas une vraie
conversation
j'aimerais vous entendre davantage sur
le québec parce que vous l'avez abordé
en parlant des négociations de l'accord
de libre échange avec l'europe
vous avez un autre partenaire au québec
qui s'appelle pablo rodriguez qui ait
lieu - du gouvernement québec
commençons comment vous vous diviser les
rôles ou est-ce que vous intervenez ou
est-ce qu'il intervient comment ça
fonctionne comment vous envisagez savent
où on verra et on doit parler plus avec
pablo mais je pense que c'est une très
importante décision à tous le premier
ministre
elle est aussi c'est important de
souligner qu' on a dit ce ministre du
québec dont le cabinet on a 35 députés
du québec et c'est très important de
parler avec notre caucus du québec avec
nos ministres du québec et je vais le
faire ah et je suis très très content
que on a un beau coup des leaders forte
du québec lequel des deux régions est la
plus problématique le québec coup
l'ouest ils ne sont pas problématiques
laquelle il de plus où se trouvait ici
le plus important l'édifice en très
différentes mais les défis autour du
pays
tous les défis sont importantes c'est
comme demander d'une mère qui elle et
l'enfant
enfin que tu préfères et qu'elle une
enfant le plus dévissé
on ne peut pas répondre aux questions
comme ça monsieur legault québec a déjà
mis sur la table un certain nombre de
demandes en matière d'immigration plus
de contrôles en immigration de respect
de la loi 101 pour les entreprises à
charte fédérale est ce qu'il ya une
ouverture de ce côté là et je pense
aussi à dans nos discussions avec le
québec à nous avons au niveau fédéral un
nouveau mandat et une nouvelle ministre
et on doit aussi avec le québec
commencée en avec une discussion je vais
dire une chose concernant a pendant la
campagne électorale
1 j'ai passé beaucoup de temps au québec
et c'était vraiment du fun
la campagne électorale au québec est
vraiment différent que à en alberta en
ontario
vraiment c'était vraiment du fun mais
j'ai écouté du côté à des entrepreneurs
la question du pénurie de main d'oeuvre
beaucoup de gens ont soulevé cette
question parce que j'ai parlé beaucoup
avec des entreprises
on a discuté à l'ena et pendant ces
conversations tour dans les mains
toujours quelqu'un a soulevé la question
du prêt de main d'oeuvre est alors je
comprends l'importance de cet enjeu pour
les gens qui y sont si importants pour
l'économie du québec
rapidement on termine à votre objectif
pour la prochaine élection d'ici à la
prochaine élection
qu'est ce que vous voulez avoir accompli
en tant que ministre des relations
intergouvernementales disponibles istres
et surtout avec à l'échelle nationale je
voudrais je voudrais commençant en
ajouter une autre chose et c'est que je
reste responsable pour les relations
entre le canada et les états unis mais
c'est une chose très important pour tout
le canada
on continue avec l'alena dans le canada
je pense que à notre cible doit être a
dû maintenir l'unité nationale dû
trouver où on peut travailler ensemble